Entanglement is often blamed for all the spooky
weirdness of quantum mechanics.
In this video I’ll explain what it really
is and one of the coolest consequences: the
EPR paradox.
If you haven’t watched any of my other videos
on quantum mechanics, you might want to watch
these two- but I’ll have a really quick
recap for everyone’s benefit
There are only 2 quantum rules we need to
give us entanglement.
The first is the superposition rule.
It says, if there are several options for
an object and if there is no way anything
can know which option the object is doing,
we say it is in a superposition of doing all
of them.
Now, importantly, this is very different from
saying it is doing one or the other, but we
don’t know which.
For example: If you flipped a coin, you may
not know whether it’s heads or tails- but
this doesn’t mean it’s in a superposition.
You know it’s one or the other, but you’re
not sure which.
A superposition is a state where a particle
seems to really do both at the same time-
at least in some interpretations.
Then there’s the measurement rule: that
if you measure a particle that’s in a superposition,
it must collapse to just one of the options
in the superposition.
Here’s how all of this can naturally lead
to entanglement.
We’ll take an example using spin- but if
you don’t know what that is, don’t worry
too much.
Imagine we have a very energetic particle
of light.
Then, using einstein’s famous formula, it
can convert that energy into mass- for example,
it could form two new particles.
But there are a bunch of conservation laws
in physics that restrict what these particles
are and what they do.
For example, a photon has no electrical charge,
so these new particles should have no charge-
in total.
So one could be an electron, and the other
a positive version of an electron- a positron,
then in total, there charge is 0.
But there’s also a thing called conservation
of spin.
Photons never have any spin, but both electrons
and positrons do.
They can either have spin up, which is positive,
or spin down, which is negative.
So for their total spin to cancel, one should
be up, the other down.
But which is which?
Usually you’d want to say, it is one of
these ways, but you don’t know which.
However, remember in quantum mechanics, if
there’s no way to know, it must be a superposition
of both.
This state is entangled- but you may not see
what’s so special about it yet.
Entanglement is the crazy property that it’s
impossible to describe the state of one of
these particles without the other.
To see what this means and why this is unique
to quantum mechanics let’s compare it to
the not quantum scenario.
Classically, we’d think it has to be one
or the other of these cases- and not both,
but we don’t know which.
Here if I wanted to describe the state of
the electron, it’d be up if the positron
is down, and down if the positron is up.
This... seems like it fits my definition of
entanglement: it’s impossible to describe
the state of the electron without talking
about the positron.
So is this entanglement?
Well actually, no.
Because really, the particles are doing one
thing, say this one.
If I knew that, I could say the electron is
up.
It’s only because I didn’t know which
case it was that I described them like this.
But in the quantum case, there isn’t this
way out.
The particles are apparently doing both these
things, and so, there isn’t an actual state
of the electron we can talk about- the electron
is not actually just up.
It’s both up if the other is down and down
if the other is up.
You can never talk about the state of these
particles seperately, only their joint state.
That’s entanglement.
But you might have an objection to this.
Can’t you say, the electron’s state is
a superposition of up and down?
Well there are two ways to show that that
isn’t the state of the electron.
The first is just mathematically showing these
two states aren’t equal, but that’s a
bit boring.
Instead, let’s see that this would lead
to a contradiction.
Suppose Alice takes the electron and Bob takes
the positron.
We’ll assume that the state of Alice’s
particle is a superposition of up and down,
and the same for Bob’s particle.
If this is actually true, then this lets us
describe the state of each particle seperately,
without mentioning the other one.
Then say Alice measures hers and finds it
to be up, so her state collapses, but Bob’s
doesn’t.
He can measure his, and get up too.
This means they started with a photon with
zero spin, and got two particles with positive
spin- which breaks conservation.
So no, the total state can’t be written
as two individual states.
The real state is this combination.
And what really happens is, Alice measures
hers, and say gets up.
Then that collapses the superposition to just
this bit.
So Bob will definitely measure down, and it
total the spin is conserved.
So we see that we have to believe the particles
are entangled to explain this.
It was Einstein though who realised the extraordinary
consequence of entanglement- and it’s very
simple.
Let’s get Alice and Bob to go very far away
from each other, and do the same experiment.
Notice something, Alice’s measurement of
her particle effects Bob’s particle, because
it has to be opposite.
Even worse, that effect has to be instant,
because if Bob measures his particle a split
second after Alice he still needs to get the
opposite result- so there can’t be any delay
in how quickly Alice’s measurement effects
Bob’s; Somehow the message from Alice’s
electron to the positron travelled instantly.
In other words, this effect is nonlocal.
The issue is, this seems to contradict Einstein’s
theory of relativity.
In that theory, no information can travel
faster than light.
The reason is that, if you could send a message
faster than light than you could cause things
like time travel and the grandfather paradox.
Einstein thought this would be enough to convince
people that Quantum theory is silly... but
what really happened was the scientific community
of the time weren’t able to come up with
a good answer to it, and decided to ignore
it.
It was wasn’t until much later that people
cared, and even later that it was proved that
the sort of spooky action at a distance in
quantum mechanics has doesn’t allow time
paradoxes- since Alice can never send any
message to bob through this.
But partly because of the nonlocality in quantum
mechanics, it still doesn’t sit very uncomfortably
with relativity.
Thanks for watching this video!
So here are some homework questions for you
to try and answer in the comments.
1 Explain why Alice can never send any messages
through this set up.
2 This is one to practice working with wavefunctions
of several objects.
Prove mathematically that it’s impossible
to write our state as two separate states
for the electron and positron
3 this one is very relevant to quantum computing.
If you have just one electron or positron,
you only need 2 numbers to describe its state.
Now suppose you have n of them.
If they are not entangled, how many numbers
to you need to describe the state?
What about for a general state that is allowed
to be entangled?